ونحييكم الى تفاصيل نقاشنا الاول اصدرت
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره توقيف بحق
رئيس روسي فلاديمير بوتين بتهمه ارتكاب
جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا منذ بدايه العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في فبراير من العام
الماضي قرار هنا ردود فعل
ترحيبيه لدى اوكرانيا والغرب كذلك بينما
كان رد الفعل الروسي رافضا وساخرا البدايه
عندما اصدرت المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
مذكرتي توقيف بحق شخصين هما الرئيس بوتين
وماريا
المفاوضه الرئاسيه لحقوق الطفل في روسيا
حيث تتهم المحكمه بوتين بالمسؤوليه عن
ارتكاب جريمه حرب متمثله في ترحيل اطفال
اوكرانيين مئات على الاقل وربما اكثر الى
روسيا الرئيس الروسي من جهته لم يعلق على
مذكره التوقيف بينما سخرت مفاوضه حقوق
الطفله الروسيه ماريا لوفوفا من قرار
المحكمه قائله سنواصل عملنا لكرملين من
جهته رفض القرار معتبرا انه باطل ولكن لان
روسيا ليست طرفا في الجنائيه الدوليه
بينما اعتبر وزير الخارجيه الروسي قرارات
المحكمه بلا معنى الرئيس الاوكراني زلزقي
يعتبر ان قرار المحكمه باصدار مذكره
اعتقال بحق بوتين تاريخي وحمل بوتين
مسؤوليه ترحيل الاف الاطفال الاوكرانيين
الولايات المتحده رحبت باصدار المذكره ضد
بوتين وقال الرئيس جو بايدن ان مذكره
الاعتقال هذه مبرره وان بوتين ارتكب بوضوح
جرائم حرب اما المتحدثه الرسميه او
المتحدث الرسمي باسم المحكمه الجنائيه
فادي العبد الله فقط اعلن ان قرار اعتقال
بوتين ليس ادانه وانما دعوه للمفعول
والتحقيق موضحا ان التنفيذ ذلك مرهون
بالتعاون الدولي
مذكره توقيف دوليه بحق بوتين اصدرت
الدائره التمهيديه الثانيه في المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه مذكرات توقيف بحق شخصين
في اطار ترحيل اطفال اوكرانيين قصرا هما
فلاديمير بوتين وماريا الفولفا بلوفا
الحكومه الاوكرانيه اكثر من 16 الف طفل
اوكراني رحلوا الى روسيا منذ بدء النزاع
وضع العديد منهم في معاهد اولد عائلات
حاضنه ماذا فعل بوتين لم يعلق على القرار
وتوجه الى شبه جزيره القرم للاحتفال
بالذكرى التاسعه لضمها ثم زار ماريوبول في
زياره مفاجئه وفي اول زياره له الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه هي هيئه قضائيه
دائمه ومستقله تاسست في يوليو عام
1998 اختصاص المحكمه يقتصر على جرائم
الاباده الجماعيه والجرائم ضد الانسانيه
وجرائم الحرب
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من موسكو لنا
المستشاره السياسيه في مركز الدراسات
الدوليه اهلا بك ومن باريس فراس الحاج
يحيى الباحث في القانون الدولي اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام الى ملفنا الاول واسمحوا لي
ان ابدا من موسكو معك
في الواقع تبعنا ردات الفعل الروسيه
والتصريحات الرسميه اتت كلها رفضه لمذكرات
الاعتقال بل وساخره من هكذا خطوه
وطبعا روسيا ليست منضمه لقرار روما
الاساسيه او قانون روما الاساسي ولكن هل
ترين اهميه تذكر في اصدار مذكره كهذه من
حيث اضعاف بوتين
ووضح بانه العمليه الروسيه هناك حتى استمر
استاذ فراس هل يمكن ان ينقلب السحر على
الساحر كما شرحت سيده ايلينا وان تدعم
مذكره الاعتقال هذه بوتين خاصه في داخل
الروسي
تحياتي لحضرتك ولجميع الساده المشاهدين
حقيقه القرار ليس بالبساطه وليس بهذه
البساطه وليس بهذه السهوله التي تحدثت بها
طيف الكريمه القرار سيكون له تداعيات
سياسيه ودبلوماسيه كبيره لانه سيزيد من
عزه روسيا عن مجتمع الدولي ويمكن ان يؤدي
الى مزيد من العقوبات والضغط الدبلوماسي
كما انه يشكل سابقا لمحاسبه القاده على
على جرائم الحرب المرتكبه في النزاعات
الدوليه بالتالي قرار المحكمه او تاثيره
يعتمد بالدرجه الاساسيه على كيفيه
استقباله من قبل المجتمع الدولي وهنا نقطه
التطور او نقطه الاهميه لهذا بهذه المذكره
حيث ردود الفعل الدولي والتي نراها الان
مرحبا من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي تؤكد ان هذا القرار
سوف يؤثر على الصراع الجاري في اوكرانيا
وسوف يزيد وسوف يكون له انعكاسات كبيره
سواء على الصعيد القانون الدولي او سواء
انا سعيد دبلوماسيه الدولي
يعني لن يؤثر فقط على صوره بوتين لن يضعف
بوتين كما يقول مراقبون وانما سيؤثر كذلك
على الصراع الدائر في اوكرانيا ما تعليقك
سيدي ايلينا
من وجهه نظرها كما يرى الروس بان هذه
المذكره هي في الواقع ليست الا خطوه اخرى
من ضمن خطوات عديده قام بها الغرب وفي
النهايه بوتين خسر في هذه المرحله علاقته
مع الغرب فما الذي يمكن ان تضيفه مثل هكذا
خطوه بحسب قراءه الروس هذه لن تكون لها
اضافه
ان من قطيعه دبلوماسيه مع اكبر القوه في
العالم مع المجتمع الدولي مع الغرب
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه سيزيدها باي
شكل نحن نتكلم العالم ليس فقط
الامريكيه والاتحاد الاوروبي يوجد دول
اخرى على سبيل المثال القمه الاقتصاديه
التي تعقد في جنوب افريقيا جنوب افريقيا
من الدول الموقعه على الاتفاقيه على نظام
روما الاساسي واتفقي على يعني الميثاق
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ايضا هذا قد
يدفع روسيا اكثر فاكثر الانسحاب من
المؤسسات واتفاقيات
بالتالي يزيد من عزيزه الدبلوماسيه واتفق
مع الضيفه فيما تفضلت اليه من ان هذا
القرار قد يزيد من قرار محكمه الجنائي
الدوليه قد يؤدي الى تصعد النزاع في
اوكرانيا لكن الاهم من كل ذلك انه يعني
ينصف الضحايا او هؤلاء الاطفال الذين تم
يعني
بالقانون الدولي وهذا هو الاساس التي يجب
ان نتحدث به هناك المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه بناء على تحقيقات استمرت سنوات
طويله
قضاتها مشهود لهم في خبرتهم الق الطويله
واحيادتهم الكبيره بالتالي هذا القرار
اليوم يعني هو خطوه الخطوه الاولى اصدار
مذكر ولكن بامكان المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه ان تصعد بهذا الجانب وهنا لابد
ايضا يعني نؤكد بان هذا القرار ليس انما
هو دعوه للمثول والتحقيق فقط بالتالي لابد
من تعاون الدول من ضويه ضمن المحكمه
حتى يتم تنفيذ مذكره الاعتقال ومذكره
التوقيف او موتور الرئيس الروسي امام
المحكمه الجنائيه طيب تحدث منذ قليل
الاستاذ التي تسي
طر روسيا الى الداخله روسيا وساعود لك
بخصوص هذه النقطه ولكن تعليقك استاذه فيما
يخص ما قاله ضيفي حول ازدياد عزله بوتين
وازدياد عزله روسيا خاصه وان هناك دول
منضويه في قانون روما الاساسي
وليست لديها مشاكل حاليا مع بوتين ولكن
يمكن ان تصطر
بحسب المتغيرات الى ان تتفاعل مع هكذا
مذكره
من خلال السنه الاخيره كان حجر جدا
وزيارته الدوليه كانت قليله ولكنه زار دول
مجاوره
واعتقد ان هذا القرار لن يؤثر على مثل هذه
الزيارات مثلا في فضاء الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابق
وبعدين امريكانا انفسهم لا يعترفون بهذه
المحكمه الجنائيه بسبب ما فعله في العراق
وفي افغانستان هذا ايضا الواضح جدا للجميع
فالمانيا قالت انها ممكن ان تضطر لاعتقال
بوتين اذا ظهر هذه ولكنه غير ناوي ان يزور
المانيا الان هناك سؤال حول قمه دول
العشرين التي ستنعقد في اول ايام من شهر
ديسمبر في نهايه هذه السنه في الهند
انا متاكده انه الهند لن تخطط اعتقال رئيس
بوتين ابدا وعلى دور زياره رفيق شيء
القائد الصيني غدا وبعد الغد الى موسكو
وهذا للتعزيز العلاقات ما بين البلدين هذه
المذكره تبدو لا شيء طيب
سنرى كيف ستتعامل مختلف الدول المنضويه في
قانون روما الاساسي بما يخص هذا الموضوع
ولكن استاذ فراس منذ قليل تحدثت عن موضوع
الاتهام محل مذكره الاعتقال او الدعوه على
الاقل للمثول للتحقيق وهو موضوع يخص
الاطفال والبعض يقول بانه هذا الموضوع
ستكون لا تداعيات وسيكون هناك تعاطف كبير
ولكن قد يكون سلاح ذو حدين خاصه وان البعض
استذكر قضايا اطفال اخرى
شهدتها سوريا مثلا ما تعليقك على ما
اعتبره البعض بمكيالين من المحكمه الدوليه
اتفق مع حضرتك بشكل كبير يعني في هذه
الناحيه
من ناحيه اليوم هل العدل او العداله تطبق
في مناطق ولا تطبخ في المناطق اخرى على
بعض البشر ولا تطبق على على بشر اخرين على
بعض الاطفال والاطفال اخرين من جنسيات
اخرى لا يطبق ذلك اليوم المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه يعني الى حد ما قد يعتقد اليوم
الاوكران انها قد انصفتهم لكن ماذا عن
الضحايا السوريين من الاطفال وغيرهم الذين
سقطوا نتيجه
القصف الروسي او المسؤوليه التي تتحملها
روسيا عن تدخلها في سوريا المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه يعني تزعم بان المتهمين
استخدموا ناصبهم في السلطه لتسهيل النقل
وترحيل الاطفال وحرمانهم من حريتهم
وتعرضهم المعامله غير انسانيه بالتالي هذه
الجريمه اعتقد بمتشابه ومتطابقه بشكل كبير
ايضا بما حصل في سوريا بذات الوقت حصل هذا
الشيء في سوريا وتم نقل اطفال وتدريبهم في
في روسيا
لا شك قرار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه هو
قرار مهم لكن ايضا العداله لا يجب ان تكون
بعين واحده كما رات الانتهاكات الروسيه
والجرائم التي جرائم الحرب التي ارتكبت
بحق المواطنين الاوكرانيه منذ عام 2014
الى الان ايضا في سوريا هناك جرائم تم
ارتكابها لم يحرك لها المجتمع الدولي اي
مناطق اخرى غير سوريا ولكن
على المشاركه من موسكونين المستشاره
السياسيه في مركز الدراسات الدوليه ومن
باريس فراس الحاج يحيى الباحث في القانون
الدولي شكرا لكما